[Music]
good good evening everyone
the topic of the lecture tonight
will be a little bit different from
what's been announced uh i apologize for
that
uh
when
i told ben like what's the name going to
be like around two in the morning
around two
o'clock i thought i will have enough
time to prepare on a castle
in the endgame which seemed to me like
as a very interesting topic because no
you know
in the in the endgame king supposed to
stay in the center most of the time to
participate in the fight
uh king can protect itself it's a strong
piece
uh we're not supposed to castle in
in the end game
uh
and i thought i'll find like a plenty of
examples of like how is it a
castle
could be only an exception to that rule
but i started doing it and
realized
just tiny i need to go from through
thousands of end game be before i can
find like
the one that i can use for that topic
and
i simply did not have enough time to
just
prepare
for the that one so
uh
we're gonna do something else today with
a little help of my friends
uh eduardo's residentalis published this
book in 2018
it's called correct exchange in the
endgame
excellent book
the second book in his series the first
one was the correct exchange in the
middle game which is
like absolutely epic on
epic work
i
went through the whole book with
my students and it was like a
real real pleasure this one uh
no exceptions the same thing
um if you'll go through the whole
book the way we're gonna be doing it
tonight
on
your end game understanding will
skyrocket
so
let me close it up uh we're just gonna
go through
the examples oops did i
no
it's fine okay
uh
how about albert
over here
all right and then whenever you're set
okay how about now
yep okay
sorry what
so we're just going to do it the puzzles
way uh in each
[Music]
diagram position we will
first we will have to identify what uh
what's there to choose from right
exchange or not
and then we'll
try to decide whether the exchange is
correct or not
so
black to move we'll see it by this
little black dot in the right corner
okay
and black to move right now so obviously
the move that we're talking about is
queen h6
so the question is if we'll play in
queen h6
are we gonna win this end game or not
what do you think
or let me put it
slightly different would you trade coins
here or you will
try to attack
attack white's position maybe put the
queen on e4 put the queen on e2 and
um threaten g2 try to bring
white queen to passive position and then
just somehow win it
on a two two one or you will play queen
h6 if you play quinn h6 then you need
like a specific setup
uh
that
i mean
the black wins this i mean after queen
h6 you need you need to see this
uh plan all the way how the black wins
so
let's do the first one just on the as a
demo i was like
so let's say we say playing queen h6 and
white has to take take and king d1
so
king goes over here
you can get three king of five
and now
two different ways for white to continue
here first let's say white just
doesn't do anything just wait
passively
stays king juan
and then
let's say we
going there and picking up the
sorry pawn on a7
and then we come back
is this position gonna be
winning or not
so here here
you can get two
this and that
okay
so
no obviously it's winning right so just
go bishop b7 waiting for one move taken
and then
coming here
king h1 what it takes
none just bishop one
you cannot take it because king h2
now we forcing king out of the corner
and black wins
okay
so
in this position oops
it's queen h4 is an important one okay
so takes
takes
uh
that means that this position is just
simply winning
for
four block
king here let's see
takes
king c4
this
here
oop no
well i'm saying
can d6 king here
you can guess six
no we're just waiting for one move the
king comes back in comes
to b7 picking up the pawn and wins
so
if white simply takes on h6 well
the win is pretty simple so queen h4 is
the only move
okay
and now
what's the win right now
okay
go ahead
so black to move
no situation is different if we'll take
on h4 that's the end game where black
will have to
fight for a draw and frankly i don't
think it will be achievable
with the pawn on h4 so black cannot
exchange coins but we need in order to
win it we need to force wire to
trade queens on h6 how do we gonna do
this king six a good suggestion okay so
i'm coming to g1
oh then it's easy right
everyone sees the
queen e3
king h2
and 24.
so no checks and checkmate on g2 is
coming so what if i go to
well that doesn't help because of this
now what if
what if i go to h1
is that gonna be different
so now you trade queens right
oh that's that's great yeah and this one
perfect
is that going to be
no it's an easy one
very good so let's see
king g6 what else can i do can i go
kenji one
oh no that we already looked at it
yeah that's it that's it
can you one
aha the last one maybe this
or to f1 instead
but then it's gonna be no couple of
checks
okay maybe maybe you're right maybe
queen c1
is better
queen c1
know what quincy one king goes back to
h2
uh
okay where is the win now
um
okay take some g3 probably the simplest
right
g3
then king picks it up
all right
is this gonna be winning okay hold on a
second 10 10
10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10
um
okay it will be
it will be winning
bishop f3 kenji one
king here
that's a draw right
uh yeah let's say we did it uh but uh
where's doing okay
okay
yeah i'm looking for i want to play
bishop f3 but i don't see
where where exactly it works because no
of course i'm not going to take it
so
here yeah
looks like it's a jar
it is a draw yeah
you gotta be careful
so
uh where is the wind right now
you can do one
check
check
this looks logical so here we go
and check
check
no prob okay probably this is just
simply winning because
well why not
uh king goes
okay and the king goes on the first rank
will trading coins
king goes to c3 we'll just go here
king goes to e3
same thing right queen h3
and
that's it
all right
so
those were
it's just like a demo or it was a little
bit more complicated than i expected but
that's what we're going to do
all right so next one
is
black to move right now
and let's try to understand what the did
you want from us here
[Music]
okay
um
is the rook takes before
and then what try to make a draw
so if we're taking on b4 and c taken b4
black cannot win it right so
rook d4 or f5 check take on h5
so it takes before pawn takes
yeah king c4
looks
logical but then why where's the correct
exchange and then i'm just doing this
time
um
are we is there gonna be traded anyway
or maybe there is no way
for
white to exchange i mean to avoid the
exchange
no but if i'll play just simply go
okay can you see four right
so what are we looking for here
no i i don't understand it okay so
i probably need to see
probably need to see what's the
king c6
king is
and what
i don't know
what did they trying to say that the
white is better in starting position and
we need to make it draw
uh
weird okay i know
next one
all right
black to move
okay
better okay
from d3
on the channel
okay so we get in this position with uh
where's the black to move
so let's try to understand what they
want us to do here um
bishop takes c6
uh
black is down upon and no questions
about black is fighting for a draw
a5
is not a threat immediately
but as a black player are we going to be
taking on c6
and white cannot take with a bishop
that's an immediate draw but rook takes
bishop takes opposite color bishop
is that gonna be a
draw or
we're gonna lose because of a point
okay so
wow this is complicated
so are we gonna
i if
knight takes f2 and bishop g4 uh you
mean bishop takes f2 and bishop g4
yeah but then knight simply moves away
yeah i don't think it's tactical it's
just a it's a question more
are we going to
save opposite color bishop position
or we'll try to defend with simply
by standing we try to defend with two
bishops because
well i'm withholding everything rook
takes
rook takes f3 and bishop takes c6 works
only for white
takes on f3 with a rook yeah but if
not
it just doesn't work
so
yeah it's more of a the question is more
like are we standing or
passively whatever king g7 or we can go
h6
or rook d6
or are we taking on c6 because now we
are forcing uh
opposite color bishops
so the this is more
same black is more
opposite
in opposite color
well so let's think about it so bishop
takes c6 white has to take with the rook
and we're taking on c6 bishop takes
so what is our setup here
king e7 king of three
king
d6
bishop b5
i'm kind of worried about like pawn on
h6 it's it's too too weak
and then
yeah i got a feeling that this this
position might be simply lost
because
uh the fact that black king is more
active the white one really
really doesn't matter like that much
because
what do we do now after no okay no uh
all right so here
okay maybe
a little bit more precise
yeah but how's precise we we cannot play
king f3 was was not a good one
so let's say here
i need to
put the pawn
on f4
like this
so can my
nfl get to h5
and then back and forth back in g4
kingdom
so
[Music]
yeah uh it looks like uh indeed yeah
opposite call of bishops
should be
should be holdable
uh
however again i'm like
in the practical game would i stay with
two bishops and just say
like two bishops are really really good
because it's a great combination of
pieces like rook and two bishops
if
you're not very familiar with like a
hierarchy of a combination of pieces so
number one is two rooks to bishops it's
absolutely the deadliest combination of
pieces in chess game
and then there comes queen and knight
and then maybe queen in two nights right
and then
uh
queen and knight and then rook and the
bishop
comes at number three yeah and those
three
combination of pieces always considered
to be an advantage so here black has an
advantage in that but
actually like for example if i'll just
go here how can
how can white possibly improve this
maybe he can slowly
but i already threatened rook d2 right
um
so let's say here
this
is their chance it should be a draw okay
uh
yeah okay yeah i don't know uh i feel
like in practical game especially if i
be low on time
i would
not take on c6
but also i understand that it's probably
the simplest
simplest way for to to draw this because
uh
i simply don't see the way that well for
in order for white to win i think king
has to get to a point and
but
no it's just not realistic that the king
will always be there
okay
one piano
yeah a5 never works that's the point
so
all right let's see what's the correct
answer
and
correct answer bishop takes c6 yeah i
don't know how they like uh this
uh
h6 king 7
bishop a5 aha so we're just
very easily holding this this way
and can never get to h6 pawn because
g3 is hanging and king taking care of a
pawn so
it's actually a pretty simple draw
yeah this is already a force draw over
here
so this is a
no
um
it's just an interesting
like a wood
yeah see engines also they don't want to
go into opposite color bishops are
exactly the same sentiment that i um
same thing that i thought i don't really
see how
white can improve this position with two
bishops on the board but
on the other hand bishop takes c6 it
would be a very very firm draw
from someone like karia can i almost
guarantee that he will go for it like us
straight away without like a
a second of hesitation so yeah
okay
king g7 is more practical
yeah but okay so i think
both
let's say this so bose moves looks like
a lead to a draw but
if we will hesitate in a game to play
bishop take c6 and then at home
we'll find out that this is a very very
easy draw was it
we want next time we
won't be able to take on c6 that's how
we're getting better in the end game
okay
even though from practical point of view
yeah kenji 7 or
d6 it's
pretty much the same okay
all right so
a way to move right now
and
what kind of exchange are we talking
about here
uh-huh i see what kind of exchange are
we talking about rook d1
uh takes takes takes on c4 d7 and we
take him back on b7
so
are we going rook f to d1 or not
rook takes
wow
so it's only three years past since i
did this book and i can tell you that i
don't remember a single one of those
positions
okay
okay rook d1
so pawns are equal the white enjoys the
better pawn structure
and
technically black holds the
holds the d file which makes his
position oh yeah and he wants
do i want to play rig d3 no i'm not not
sure i do
so rook d1
why not
e1 for example
because then
i can go like knight to d2 right and
activate my rook so rook to d1 prevents
it let's say king of fate
and then
king of f8 on what then
and then we'll be taking on d8
no but that that's
giving up this all right rook d1 and
king f8
do we want to trade one pair of
and then
start bringing our king to the center
right king of one can get two can get
three
and
yeah i would if
you asked me about like the correct
exchange here i would say that uh it's
more important to trade a pair of
knights rather than
a pair of rooks would be
yeah okay
95
um
i hope it does not drop the pawn after
knight d2 and f6
i hope it's not but you know who knows
and uh also knight f6 bishop f 95 sorry
a bishop f6 what happens then
so
okay so i wonder if like a question of
exchange here is about like we're
playing rook d1 trading rook or we're
playing rookie one
and trying to exchange the knight
and we should not be afraid of knight d2
because that helps us out
right and then
when
black plays knight d2 well then we take
and then we go rook f2 d1 then
because this way we guarantee that we're
gonna make it to
to d7
so maybe
this first
and
okay knight d turn knight d6 that's what
we want
because knight d6 will simply
take it right and go
or d1
is that correct
okay let's see
there we go
c4 is hanging so
we'd better take
take
no yeah it's going to be very unpleasant
end game for for black hint goes to the
center
pawns are weak and gonna remain likely
if we trade rooks it will be simply lost
for black i mean it's too passive
so
i would say rookie one but uh it's quite
possible this is a
what they want us to but i just don't
really understand how that
helps us out after king f8
yeah i don't see it so
let's see
what's the
solution here is
rook f2 e1 is correct but
they saying black is better no i think
it's a mistake it cannot be better like
how is it
response like this better i mean the
position is drawn even if we exchange
this 3 for this too
so
i think it's just a mistake here
okay yeah here of course
that's why the book is written i'm sure
the plenty of comments and
in the book so it will be helpful to
read it i just don't want to open it up
at the moment just
hoping
okay
yeah so it was more important to
exchange knight here than exchange the
rook but i think that was the question
yeah i know it's it's a complicated it's
a
like what i'm trying to say it's a
grandmaster level puzzles it's the
uh
with no clear solutions it's it's not
like you know it's not doratsky it's a
it's an end game book that uh
you can put a lot of your own insights
like when you're working on it
uh
i remember like i could not beat my
students in a lot of those puzzles which
is like they were saying okay this
and uh
i just
really there's nothing
i could have done
so right well hopefully it will be
better like uh as we're going on
okay oh no check this out okay rook f2d1
takes takes
no okay well
aha so here we trade in it not
so this is like a
and now we're playing knight d2 trading
this knight and then there is no defense
against rook d7 okay
i got it but uh
i think rook takes taking on d1 giving
up d file and then go rook takes c4 it's
just irresponsible for black
and he should just wait
oh that's already the next one okay
sorry about this bishop d sound here
like we'll skip it
we'll go
straight to the next
one all right wait
to move
okay
a correct exchange right here
um
okay so
yeah you know what i i just i cannot
leave it like this uh let me
just get back
and see after king of faith are we
missing something obvious
rook f2 d1 and king of eight
no it's equal right it's just uh
that's what i thought we'll take we'll
go king of one can get two no white will
be pressing but uh not not as much yeah
okay
so i'm not sure what this example was
all about
so turn
okay bishop d7 we saw it here here okay
so white to move and
uh
we need to make a decision on whether or
not to trade or
whether we play or not we're playing
rook takes e7
i don't think there's any tactics left
were we keeping two rooks on the board
okay we're keeping two rooks on the
board probably
i wanted to say we should not allow
rookie 2 but
now that i'm thinking about it really
doesn't matter
no it does
so if we go rook d5 rookie 2
oh then we go rook d2 and rook
definitely standing that that's much
better version of exchanging
than right now right
uh rook takes e7 king takes e7
and then what
can c2
and if we'll go rook d2 right now
just not allowing
black just not giving black any
yeah maybe
how about rook 7 to d2 and then slowly
started improving our position with king
c2 and b3 and c4
and so on uh our rooks are much more
active than our opponent's rook so
i believe we do not trade rooks here
and rook d5 rookie 2 i'm not sure how
we're supposed to deal with it
oh okay well b2 is not hanging at the
moment maybe this is the
the answer but
well well how we defined in b2
yeah i'll play rook 3 to d2 here let's
see that that's what they want us
from here
oops
home
wow okay
however they saying taking on before
is also good
so compare you see computer also in
between the same dilemmas that we had
taken and before and then just to bring
king and improve it or go rook
7 to d2
objectively
it's the same
wow
you see this someone analyzed it to the
depth of 31.
so this is a
rook 7 to d2 stock fish
and
looks a little different
okay
uh
let's see
what's the answer
okay but we know that this is not a
final answer
so rook 7 to d2 exclam okay
so i would imagine that he tries to
explain in the book that we don't trade
in active rook
and then
let's look at it slowly improving
our position
okay
here we trading fixing pawn on the dark
square
wow
that's a lot of maneuvering
and finally white king here makes it
true
okay
very good technique what can i say no
all right looks
white to move
and since we're talking about trading it
uh rook c5 right
yes or no
so rook c5
rook c5
uh idea rook c5 might be rook 1 to b5
rook 1 to b5 and attack the pawn but i
still don't understand how it works if
so for example black passes right and
one to b5 pawn is not hanging at the
moment because
oh it does no because i'll take on c5
right
so
all i have to do right now i
i need to move with my king away from
the from the check
so
where did i move
oh also threaten to take on
c7
and then win the pawn
so maybe
here right
that's correct
centen
uh
[Music]
takes takes
okay
so
so it's a combination of things so here
we go rooks is five think here
let's say we're trying to make it
here we go h6
where is the break
like rock b5
oops
b5 and
indeed where is the break
yeah
trading for black is bad on c5 because
mainly because white king gets to d4
like uh yeah the rest would be like
acceptable but
this makes d5 forever forever weak and
some kind of a break with a a6 or b8
combined with c6 will win the game
immediately for white so no black cannot
afford to break but i don't understand
like where where's the
or is the breaking through
so
rook b5 and
can d8 so let's try it on
find a way to
do it
here so take takes
aha
i think i got the idea
okay how about you do do you see the way
for white to
make a progress here
sacrificing the bishop i don't think it
will help that much because uh
i keep in the blockade
okay
so i see two ways to go for weight i
mean the one is
like a straightforward sack just to give
it up
no and hope that our
uh two connected points
will make it right and
actually
so takes takes
no
is that winning
if bishop goes away and then we go d5
i'll go rook c5 and i'm not
not sure okay we can go h5 right so
takes takes
oh uh
h5 right and this is
that doesn't look good
yeah then then two pawns just went so
either this one or another uh version of
it is just to go a4
uh black passes no i know it doesn't
matter which way and now we're taking
that way
takes and this one
okay i mean i i put my kink in
on a bad position so let's say just this
oh it doesn't work
because
sorry uh i'll take on b5
yeah and then block is good okay so king
king is seven
no it doesn't no now i can take right
bishop takes d5 so black
black
setup is extremely
difficult here i mean
if
i need to pass but maybe i i simply
don't have a move
oh
it's no more for black it took time
so let's say here
this
yeah we have to do this
rook takes d5 there's no other way
and then
hope that will win here
okay
so no
obviously that's the only way for white
to to play for a win in this position
everything else is just
well that's what i said now
that i've said it now i see the a4
whatever a6
b6 a5
also makes a lot of sense
so
maybe this one huh
you saw an a6
it takes
yeah i mean it's just not a good
position
all right well so it's between rook c5
and a4
no
if it's a4 i don't think this position
would uh
appear in this book so it must be
rook c5 let's take a look at the answer
rook c5 exclam
do they say anything about a4
a4
h6 a6 okay what's the computer thinks
about it
all right once i gave it to him well he
started saying yeah maybe
but it did not look at it uh
on his own
and
so rook c5 okay now let's see
uh
what's the
book line king 7 drug b5
rook takes c5
rook takes c5 already forced
takes
indeed
now a6
and
here comes like a beautiful tactic so b6
it's a very cute move
and
bishop g8 yeah this
a white breakthrough
and position becomes winning
uh no that was not very complicated but
uh
okay yeah rook c5
was the way to
improve it and go through
let let me close this one so
we won't see a solution for next
save no
okay
here we go
so
[Music]
let's try to understand what they want
from us here
correct exchange that means
we can take on
okay
let's try to figure it out so two
bishops for for white white has an
advantage but
the pawn
on
g4 is hanging
if we go g5
then knight g4 check king of four
and what
take on g5
g5
g5 g5 g5 um
okay
take the knight and pawns might belong
terms of the light square bishop okay so
i'll turn it uh we chosen here between
g5
which looks like okay a normal move with
a
bunch of different lines after that
and bishop takes e5 if we do this
we need to fix the h and g pawn on the
on the light squares and go
g5 next move
and then after bishop e6
my understanding that uh
if we don't have bishop c4 then it's all
like completely useless
so
it's a forced line bishop takes g5
bishop b6 bishop c4
and we need to unders
understand that whether it's winning or
not
okay let's continue the line bishop
takes c4 takes
king goes to
uh-huh
um
we can play b4 right but then i don't
understand what what in the world did we
achieve like by by exchanging bishops
my whole point was to fix dark square
pawns on h7 and g6 so that bishop can go
to g8 if we don't have it just like
okay you you're saying that we might fix
the the other pawns as well right okay
so bishop e6 b4
um
king to d7 a5
and
king to c7
and how we're gonna break through
black's next move is b5
so take stakes
g5
bishop e6
this before takes takes king seven
see i need to play c5
king d7
king d3 king c6 king c4
that looks like a draw to me
yep
uh
again yeah in the game definitely
definitely g5
but uh
if g5 is the answer then i don't really
understand why
it's given to us as a problem so
there might be some launt
on d5
exhaustion yeah i know
uh it's exhausting and position is super
simple right and it's exhausting even to
think about like when the line started
going like more than four moves you're
like
do i really need it you know
it's a simple end game like do i really
need to calculate all this and just like
why not
to play a simple g5 and keep the
pressure on and
so
what if you suck g points of the can uh
can comes in a four uh how do you suck
the jeep on kind d4
in d4
knight takes g4
um
and then you go
king c5
knight goes to f2
that's a lot of counter play isn't it
king of two
a little worried that this might be a
lot of uh on the other hand
so kindy for knight takes g4
the opposite color bishops we it's just
a draw
so king c5 knight f2
king b6 knight takes e4
bishop
b4
and then
bishop c6 bishop takes a6 that's not bad
i like it
that's a winning chances so
kindy for
what if bishop takes
g4
and then if we take taking c5 king d7
and king protects the pawn so king d4
bishop takes g4
uh yeah i think we're a little bit late
here because
king of one king
knight c6 check and king d7
what about king f4 okay what about it
um
probably
probably knight f7
bishop c5
and g5 check right with fixing points
and then
check check
and
i knock engage knight h6 try to win a
pawn so let me see it so here we go and
10
where would we go if we go to c7
check and can be seven so i want to stay
here but then check
this one
here and if i go
g3
this and the king
and king comes in knight d6 now it
doesn't feel
convincing so
this is better
so knight f7 bishop four
can you sound
aha maybe here we go
all right
king d4 and then going for the knight
this definitely looks like a pressure
and
if king d4
yeah but at the moment the pawn is
hanging so
we can only do it
right here in d4 first
and then go
no okay here we go
before
[Music]
text takes kindy sound
[Music]
it's very close to draw
all right here
king 6
check
yeah i'm afraid we're never not going to
be able to win it it's just like
the night is too mobile here
on the other hand
no
okay
all right so let's
go back and let's
see
the solution here
all right g5
is the correct one
okay i hope that this is the or there is
the next one as well no it's already a
different one okay
well previous so g5 correct
knight f7
bishop f4 takes
and
bishop takes
okay why this is important
because if we're taken with a pawn
um that looks like a pressure for white
still so bishop takes bhp six
uh
where's the wind
okay
that's to win
slowly but surely okay
all right so
so the key was here to take it was a
bishop and not was the point
so this was a correct exchange in you
okay
you know still i'm looking at it and i'm
like probably as puzzled as you are like
is that really i mean
that deep
okay
because uh
yeah but uh
you know uh like today for some reason
it's different from what like uh like i
said
went through the whole book with with my
students
around like 1900 to 2200 and
uh
i remember it was difficult but i just
i did not remember that it was that
difficult so i know maybe
it's just me you know
i'm like really declined in three years
and it's just like don't see anything
and
that it's in fact not not difficult at
all i'm just
so
anyways uh what i want
it's the book the fear feel like uh end
game
uh
and game fans uh very very very
interesting okay a lot of
examples are
discussable let's put it
very mindly over there
but
rosenthalis
is eduardos rosentalis
lithuanian grand master who probably i
i'm not sure if he lives in israel right
now or he just
spent a lot of time it still represents
lithuania
uh
always been planned this way the
not even like you know some people
planned for
minimal advantage this guy was always
playing for something next to nothing
every like
and never the less he made like
unbelievable career probably out of the
end games like this okay
and the
probably he was trying to teach us like
his way of playing chess which is like
you know
everybody has his own way that's what's
what i can say to me uh
that's
very tiring when you know squeezing the
water out of the stone like in here
but
a lot of people might find it's like
very very attractive way of playing it
because basically you're not allowing
your opponent any winning chances so a
lot of people appreciate it
so
this is uh
this is a book if you're interested
i again it's a gm level puzzle so very
very difficult ones and
i guess this is it for today yeah sorry
about the little
mess and the show because
sometimes the puzzles are too hard even
for
presenters so well that's what happened
today
okay guys well thank you for being here
tonight and uh
alex shabalov that was a
um
and tuesday end game lecture at the
saint louis
chess club and
i'll talk to you tomorrow
bye
[Music]
you